bella tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fatti j
ed ora ci siamo sul quarto è
fottutamente ultimo capi soldi proves
quest quindi sutor basket 4 è questo
tizio mi sta irritando tutti ragazzi
direi di iniziare vediamo rifinire che
questa così ci siamo e dove l'aveva
detto che sto tizio mi stava sul culo
già la prima è la cosa pazzesca mia mi
ha spinto lato qualche bastardo di merda
mi ha spento la torcia lurido viene i
due ragazzi ma è anche vero che bella
faccia già sto tizio un espressione di
gioia pazzesca e non ho capito che cazzo
devo fare ci sono sì così 15 io devo
devo accendere il calderone come cazzo
faccio è una cosa a me già ci siamo
incasinati siamo appena partiti non è
neanche c'è buco di culo
raga mi ero dimenticato cristo gioco per
la mente per andare avanti degli devi
beccare cose che non c'entrano in poche
parole vai così perfetto del miur ad
imèr dobbiamo peccare alla razzia devi
guarda bene guarda bene qui lo vedi lo
vedi dove c'è la mia faccia spara se io
prego il fucile e spara così se io se io
prego la cosa spara ken che cazzo mi
cambia non ho capito il senso ci aiuti a
meno che non si leva come negli altri
avvicinare non si avvicina cioè negli
altri servizi a meno sì sì lo sapevo lo
sapevo lo sapevo e ci avrei scommesso
adesso lo prendi
migliorano prende vi dico a 20 pt tira
una testata che si è bello così
bellissimo perfetto questo alimento di
aver vinto perché sto combattendo contro
un cazzo di pupazzo di neve non ha senso
come la fa tenere la spalla non c'ha le
mani cioè non posso saltare io non posso
saltare io per facciata dall'arci le
nuove si è fatto cazzo tizio lega a il
sole che hanno sfasciato pupazzo diverse
voglio morire adesso chi è sto tizio
chicco quanto sei bello tu che mi rubi
la merenda la mattina devo prenderti a
cazzotti allora sorge questo pezzo di
merda ma sto tizio victor casinò non è
nessuno non è nessuno le pubblico le
applicazioni o frane chiedevo io ho un
consiglio ma va ci vai mai dal dentista
abbiamo già un bel gioco
[Musica]
ma chi è che non vedo l'ora di finire
tra il fitness ragazzi e una serie di
videogiochi che mi ha accompagnato per
talmente tanto tempo che il suo chi
cazzo è quel tizio ragazzi non sa se ben
ferma o gatto affermato gates ma che
cazzo feriti ma perché io sembro
leonardo di caprio
vabbè regalo ma senza concreti continua
a trivellare qui è quello a rompermi i
[ __ ] che atipico la testata alla
prima fermati strozzi è andato brega
non so neanche non so cosa fa non me lo
chiedete non ho idea
ragazzi non ho capito nulla ma non ipa
vai così consento sugli sci lo prendo il
gol regala al volo al volo ma [ __ ]
devo prendere come devo fare spiegate
fermati stronzo ferro alcune fascio
allora fermina fermo
ok è qui ci sta una musica epica
ops mi dispiace sono minchiate lo stavo
immaginando e del successo ragazzi
assurdi chiavi non e non ci fa di giuro
che non ho guardato nulla vi giuro è una
cosa pazzesca regala non ci penso che
cosa fa
cosa fa esattamente se io io io ma non
così son capace anch'io a vincere
olimpiadi vado io porca [ __ ] ragazzi
non ho capito il senso ma non importa
perfetto il tiro mamma mia che che tu
sei un campione olimpionico sei un
campione un cd cosa c'è di gino alessio
sopra asilo staccato vai così nola
l'altra parte cosa devo fare qui
clicchiamo c'è il cd digitale se almeno
ascoltatelo lo tira cosa fare sì vinto t
da perfetto ragazzino domani voglio
vedervi tutti alle finestre che lanciate
in cd perché funziona così potete
vincere le medaglie io ve lo dico una
cosa poi cos'è questo perché si muove
sto pacco cosa c'è di strano
ho mangiato qualcosa estonia morto
fantastico è una perfetta la bancarella
del doping ha vinto tutto e la cosa c'è
qualcosa tra l'altro qui è un'altra
pastiglia ma è normale che mi è piaciuto
il naso da pinocchio
adesso adesso posso prendere anche
questa o muoio muoio lo stesso la morale
che non c'è bisogno di essere pinocchio
non è solo perché tanto se ti do p perde
in capire che cazzo da fare qui allora
ciò allora il naso il naso lo prendo per
l'economia serve e poi non ho capito
questo non lo fermi fermino trovate
altre
lo trovate a quante sono che cazzo mi
sono cresciute le ali
mi sono cresciute le orecchie mi ha
cresciuto il bello mi ha cresciuto e mi
è cresciuto lì dietro le corna e
l'ultimo level ultime per il pene sicuro
ma è la corda
spero spero sia una coda con un altro
quanti cazzo cioè sono alle tele sette
ragazzi rivesta ditemi che non è l'uomo
più seducente che abbiate mai visto e
dall'altro perché c'è posso cliccar e il
naso a nome me ne vado posso andarmene
così
perfetto ho creato un mostro domani lo
vedrete nelle vetrine dei migliori
negozi di alta moda sicuro perché
veramente sexy
se io clicco il pubblico più perfetto
canta il coro il coro su comando
cosa ne pensate l'ipo vj gelato alla
vaniglia per tutti e poi velo fiat e
laica pranzi ragazzi ormai sono
condizionati a tutto non c'è bisogno era
ora che c'è la carica puoi andare vai
zio dovresti aggrapparti su qualcosa non
prenderlo attestate maledizione devo
fermi fermi che cos'è sto coso mi sono
allungato le gambe mettendo mina presa
nel culo adesso adesso ce la fai
sì per farmi gli abbiamo creato super
nel fantastico è la cosa che madonna
quanto sei muscoloso dai che ce la fai
dai che ce la fai sì grandissima ha
perso miglia perché si tuffava meglio di
me comunque devo cliccare qualcosa che
non sto venendo cosa cazzo duplicare
fermi c'è il d'occhio occhio la finestra
la finestra alto 100 alcun modo ma che
già sta già sto tizio le tette le terre
non sono le tette anni
[Musica]
[Applauso]
che mi sta vendendo lernia
no non è neanche con perfetto io pensavo
che dovessi cliccare tante volte il
pubblico ma non è così volevo fare qui a
mentro applaudono mentre applaudono
l'intro blogo no mica ragazzi metallo se
non applaude la gente non ci vien grande
così doveva applaudire la gente se non
ci riusciva perfetto vediamo se stavolta
be back io sono sempre qui
ok niente raga niente niente impossibile
madonna senza sei bello zio
sì lo penso anch'io chi ride e [ __ ]
cazzo sono io questo sono cupe a bello
mi hanno rappresentato anche su tre file
quest un cazzo proprio devono fare il
contatore
i temi che è una presa per il culo i
ragazzi io non ho fottutamente parole
non ho fatto cosa fa ha cambiato finisse
il limbo cosa fa oliver phelps perché
possa gli occhiali da sole non ha senso
perché io mi scervello mezz'ora e poi
sono queste le soluzioni maledizione per
che cosa fai
ma che cazzo fa male dissi ma cosa farai
stai fermo un attimo cosa perché di
ritirare testata focoso a temi la mano
regala che cazzo non fare clicchiamo in
mezzo quando non clicca piovere non c'è
una stella
c'è la stella l'ho vista l'ho vista l'ho
vista lo sapevo lo so cazzola sto tizio
regala una capra ha trasformato
l'attrezzo in una capra fantastico è una
adesso posto perfetto per questo
ragazzino olimpiadi più serie d e che io
abbia mai visto in tutta la mia vita e
attenzione il signore e signori prof
leicester andremo a sollevare un peso di
altrettante 2 milioni di kg con i suoi
braccioni muscolosi no effettivamente
mi sembra che ti stai sforzando per fare
la cacca in una maniera mai vista
ragazzi sto tizio mangia troppa
vitasnella che cazzo da fare che non
prenderla d'estate devo spingerlo si è
gonfiato e adesso adesso se adesso che
bel calama ragazzi 8 tel
lo yacht dove abbiamo un delfino pesce
sega e poi c'è poi c'è sto tizio
bellissimo che affonda fantastico non
devo farlo affondare chiesto tizio col
berretto che fu padre padrone non farmi
capire una fondata poi c'è anche questa
perfetto l'ultima se e adesso c'è adesso
ce la dovremmo fare a meno che non debba
fare qualcosa con questi non ero ok è
grandissimo e che cazzo servivano stipe
sci non facciamoci domande chi se ne
frega tanto passare andiamo avanti cos'è
questo scende scende veloce è poi così
verso l'infinito e porca [ __ ] che volta
ragazzi ho dato una facciata incredibile
forse non doveva andare così veloce
oh sì devo fare ok si finisce è apparso
finish non so come appalto felice
perfetto raga siamo al diciottesimo le
macchine non due non ci posso credere
alla ticosa clicco che cazzo ride dopo i
cani non si no si è cosa ho fatto
siamo tutti i secondi come faccio poi
vai su vai su stai per vincere hai vinto
ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta non ci posso
credere 19 manca mi manca un 2 è sì ma
anche a questo è un altro la possiamo
fare è svenuto lo so che sei stanco lo
so che vorresti fare altro ma ti prego
arriviamo alla fine non mi svenire che
vorrei capire più che altro ma chi cazzo
non iscritti alla maratona se non
avevate una cazzo di voglia di correre
non ha senso
cosa ho preso o personaggio nel fuoco le
forze di te e non è suo compleanno però
se vinci ti regala una torta ti prego
vai affanculo fai qualcosa nuovi tica da
lattine la frutta forma
bisognava bruciarli le chiappe mi sembra
giusto l'ultimo a livello a ragazzi
l'ultimo livello sei bellissimo alla tua
prima mi piace
[Musica]
chi cazzo sono messo dei secoli ma ce
l'ho fatta
allora prima abbia vinto tutte le coppe
primo del mondo è pazzesco e alla fine è
alla fine diventai un ubriaco su una
poltrona fantastico abbiamo vinto trofei
square 4 in una maniera c'è l'ultimo
livello io non l'ho cliccato la prima
cosa a caso è cioè non so con che culo
possa ricapitarmi una cosa del genere
comunque una volta che si conosce più o
meno la com'è fatto tra per questa la
fine c'è le cose diventano abbastanza
semplice comunque ragazzi a meno che non
facciano 5
io però la saga di troppo spesso finita
grazie a dio e quindi ragazzi fatemi
sapere se quando ci la 5 volete vi
faccio anche quello con che ragazzi
direi che posso concludere qui come al
solito 6.000 piaciuto lasciato un
commento mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook e come non divido tolate nella
descrizione a certi rischi di
iscrivetevi lì ci dimettiamo lo fosse
unito belle ragazze
[Musica]